thanks for being here today speaking to
afghan journalists at the nato base in
kabul
us general scott miller described the
beginning of the end for foreign troops
in afghanistan
all of our forces are now preparing to
retrograde
officially the notification date will be
the first of may
but at the same time as we start taking
local actions we've already begun that
proof of the departure can be found at
this kandahari scrap heap
the owner now the proud recipient of
unwanted or broken equipment from
kandahar
airfield a key american base over the
last 20 years
you can find containers refrigerators
chairs tables and anything you would
need
generators and even some stuff in
working condition you can find anything
from around the world
the trump administration and the taliban
had agreed that foreign forces would be
gone by may 1st
if the taliban negotiated with afghan
leaders and cut ties with al-qaeda
this month u.s president joe biden
announced a new plan
the u.s will leave by september 11 but
with no conditions this despite a recent
u.n report
that up to 500 al-qaeda fighters remain
in afghanistan
as close allies of the taliban general
miller with his leverage gone
issued this warning as far as a
relationship between al qaeda and the
taliban the taliban have to break that
relationship
that is something they have committed to
and
the world expects them to break that
relationship and certainly that
afghanistan will never be used as a safe
haven for terrorism
yet it's hard to break a relationship
you don't have
the taliban has long denied there are
any al-qaeda members in afghanistan
they are quick however to confirm their
attacks on sunday alone
they published 16 posts on their website
boasting of killing dozens of afghan
soldiers and police officers in recent
days
few could be verified miller is
america's longest serving commander in
afghanistan
he has tried to reassure afghan security
forces
saying he'll leave them with as much
equipment as possible
it's my objective to make ensure that
the afghan security forces
are in the best possible security
posture and that means
transitioning bases and equipment to the
afghan security forces more than 10
000 u.s and coalition troops need to
leave afghanistan within five months
as numbers dwindle the pentagon has sent
two b-52 bombers to qatar
and will keep an aircraft carrier in the
region as cover
in case of taliban aggression charlotte
bellis al jazeera